blistering cold  hurricane force winds  and close to 50 inches of blinding snow  officials are calling the Christmas  blizzard the worst winter storm to blow  through Buffalo this blizzard is the one  for the ages certainly it is the  Blizzard of the century at least 28  people have died in Western New York and  the death toll is only expected to rise  New York Governor Kathy hokel says she's  spoken to many First Responders as the  search rescue and Recovery continues  going into homes going into vehicles and  too many tragic times of finding people  who did not survive the experience the  storm is forcing driving bans to  continue in Buffalo and surrounding  communities with the Lesser travel  advisories everywhere else many on  Buffalo's East Side are still stuck in  their homes while Vehicles still litter  side streets and highways